Cómo logra la figura de quemal kilish
darulu unir a la oposición casi que por
primera vez en los comisos en los
comicios recientes de Turquía
pues es bastante Interesante como
sucedió eso yo lo considero como un acto
bastante pragmático porque a pesar de
que tengan diferencias y de ideológicos
vamos a decir de que tenían un enemigo
en común Entonces como estadísticamente
bien y este observando que Michael ha
sido el líder más popular entre otras
personas que estaban sentados sobre Esa
mesa yep tradicionalmente y
históricamente ha sido el partido más
popular a comparación de otros partidos
que se sentaron en la mesa para formar
la alianza si es un es un pragmatismo
porque hay un interés en común y pues
también aquí o sea vemos explícitamente
como todo lo que propone ahorita pues
están proponiendo como un un cambio
bastante ambicioso que también va a ser
o sea sería como bastante retador
implementarlo pues está está
replanteando un posible reajuste con los
intereses de la otan una confirmación de
la aspiración de Turquía de convertirse
en miembro de la Unión Europea aunque
sea bastante complejo pues allá está la
probabilidad de fortalecimiento de las
credenciales democráticas de Turquía y
continuación del enfoque equilibrado de
Turquía hacia Rusia y china porque pues
son dinámicas que no pueden cambiar
drásticamente pero al mismo tiempo Hay
ciertos retos que van a seguir
permaneciendo Aunque GP o esa Alianza
este estuviera en el poder por ejemplo
el tema del estatus de chipre o las el
tema de las fronteras marítimas con
Grecia y el acuerdo migratorio se
seguirían siendo asuntos delicados tal
como tal como la postura de Estados
Unidos hacia Siria que seguiría siendo
como un un tema problemático Entonces
tampoco podemos decir que que o sea el
opositor está proponiendo solución a
todo porque Turquía tiene una agenda
bastante amplia pero sí está proponiendo
hay ideas bastante diferentes a lo que
era jettai perdón ha hecho en los años
pasados porque incluso hemos mencionado
el alojamiento de de la Unión Europea y
también ese hartazgo de llevar tantos
años en el proceso de adjeción que
también cierto cierto parte de la
población ha apoyado directamente un
acercamiento directo hacia medio oriente
pues esos fueron como las ideas
promovidas por parte de perdón entonces
creo que la figura de que Michael es
popular Porque es diferente a
comparación de lo que ha vivido Turquía
entonces mucha gente lo ve como una
posible solución dado que ha sufrido
muchos como muchos momentos de crisis
como como la chica que entrevistaron que
que es de cierta generación y dice que
pues yo no he visto algo más entonces
es una figura de cambio Es por eso que
se unificaron y fue como una decisión
pragmática más que ideológica